[Musique]
l'express a bien mais ça se passe en moi
c'est que je flippe air qu'on aménage
ensemble est en fête
bah ça se passe grave ni amour choqué
par andy collines boisées trop cool bien
et a toujours pas loïc quoi c'est le hic
c'est quand il ya des trucs qui commence
à s'énerver ou est dégoûté chez
quelqu'un qui te souhaite un petit peu
trop tôt parce que franchement mec qui a
qu'à toi que ça et c'est le genre de
truc j'ai eu pas je suis hyper moss de
fred pourquoi il y aurait des trucs qui
me dégoûte c'est dingue quand même comme
tu es pessimiste tu vois tu peux pas
croire que juste une relation roule
normal si excuse moi
[Musique]
ça va bien dormi c'est lui qui sait
quand y'a des trucs qu'ils commencent à
peu à t'énerver des petits trucs qui
commença d'écouté
[Musique]
images c'est mc nish portée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
7 qu'est ce que tu m'as fait bon jouer
[__] mais qu'est ce que tu n'as fait
le truc dont tu m'as parlé l'autre fois
là le luc
ouais bah je crois que je l'ait pas bon
mais tu me disais qu'avec ferait tout
allait bien je crois encore mais tout va
bien tout va bien avec fred
mais je sais pas je le supporte plus
quoi je supporte plus la manière qu'il a
de manger je te jure j'ai jamais entendu
quelqu'un faire autant de bruit que ça
bouffe quoi marquer le coup quand et les
biscottes et cette façon qu'il a c'est à
dire qu elle n y qu elle aime comme à
coup avec son mac sommaire delà tenait à
cergy pour coup et est ce que c'est le
bien c'est qu'il est en train de donner
l'argent déjà fait remarquer en ont tous
remarqué la semaine environ
non mais c'est tout simple qui tu le
laisses pas grave tu peux te quitter je
vais pas le quitter parce qu'ils mangent
des pistes quote moi j'ai peut-être une
solution mais je te préviens c'est
définitif
[Musique]
bonjour désolé j'ai besoin de me brosser
les dents ce matin
tu manges le matin non non voilà je suis
ému m non mais c'est super c'est
important de manger le matin de sa faute
d un petit canot n'y avait un petit coup
ni la housse aux caisses qu'il ya un
pardon mais bain ou supercherie à bout
voilà torrent sais où tu as vu
ouais non mais attends ça marche tout
tes conneries là il ya déjà les rapports
depuis des mois j'ai même une grande
donnée là que je colle tous les matins
sur good je n'ai je pu la question me
gêne toujours aimé qu'elles sont
franchement dire une déchetterie non
elle doit être à être à fond je sais pas
et bah bravo bienvenue chez les
célibataires comme quoi l'amour ça tient
pas à grand chose
du coup tu tu t'es mis du vinaigre dans
la chatte sur tous les sites à l'onu
pour toutes à partenaires et bas à bonn
toi parce que comme ça tu vas voir
d'autres vidéos et puis ça détournera
l'attention du fait que tomber coûte à 9
soit vraiment dégueulasse ce qui me
dégoûte avec sa gueule de mer chaque
matin et s'est disputée qui fait du vrai
que ça bouge à ce que j'aimerais que ma
vidéo